- Many are upset that Biden's DOJ
seems to be defending President Trump
in the E. Jean Carroll case,
where he is accused of sexual assault.
And this one is more
complicated than it seems.
This all relates to the Westfall Act
which basically gives immunity to
employees of the government
who undertake actions
in the course of their employment.
And it's not unreasonable to assume
that allegations of sexual assault
don't relate to the course
and scope of your employment
as a federal employee,
but it's more complicated than that.
The E. Jean Carroll case relates
to former President Trump's
statements while in office,
she's accusing him of defamation
by denying the allegations,
and defenders of this move point out that
politicians have to talk
about their personal lives
in office all the time.
Number two, that if
these kinds of statements
we're not immune, you get
all kinds of crazy suits
anytime any politician said anything.
And number three, there
is prior case law where
a politician has received
Westfall immunity
when talking about their
personal lives in office.
But bottom line,
this is a complicated issue
and there are no easy answers.